three reasons or top three things that I  got out of the NBA for myself and the  first is for sure amazing connections so  especially the inside of me babe but I  trust your assets and garden it's no  different you meet so many people in the  MBA program from so many different  regions and geographies I know for  myself that if I want to travel in  almost every country in the world it's  more or less guaranteed that I will know  a person there that at least will be  able to have someone introduce me there  to a person to a local who could maybe  guide me around potentially even give me  a place to sleep and of course this is a  network that also other professional  side it's extremely valuable a recently  was looking for contacts at a specific  company I was looking the company up on  LinkedIn and I saw that several of my  old MBA friends were working at that  company that of course is huge and  really a great opportunity to tap into